se détendre avec une promenade en forêt
et écouter le bruit de la nature tout
cela en se faisant masser sur un
fauteuil
voilà un des programmes de 6 kg cette
cabine bien-être développé au ski cube
c'est une machine apparemment commune
mais en fait qui se sert en fait des
nouvelles techniques de massage et
notamment en fait des airbags
on conçoit des programmes avec des
professionnels de
de la sophrologie des hypno thérapeutes
voilà tout et science on ressent quand
même constitué par des gens dont c'est
le métier
les séances durent entre 20 et 30
minutes cette start up lancée en 2016
incuballiance de paris saclay s'est
installé en janvier 2010 cette hausse
qui kube hôtel entreprises centres de
fitness ou de thalasso cyclo souhaite
mailler le territoire avec cette cabine
via un système de location on est en
train de créer du bien-être automatisés
c'est j'ai une pression je l'enlève à
l'instant t
c'est à dire quelle que soit l'heure du
jour et de la nuit
j'aurai toujours une cabine aux à
proximité qui me permettra de me
détendre en créant des événements à
l'intérieur de l'entreprise pour essayer
de déstresser les gens que j'ai pris
conscience qu'il fallait automatiser le
système pour finaliser l'automatisation
du système la start up va se lancer dans
une campagne de levée de fonds à travers
un tour de france
objectif récolter 500 mille euros on
s'est dit bon on va aller chercher
l'humain pour pouvoir financer ce projet
et c'est pour ça qu'on a choisi un
modèle qui s'appelle le crowfunding en
royalties
la participation au financement du
projet permet de gagner une part du
chiffre d'affaires pendant cinq ans
trois fois le montant investi en cours
de finalisation le tour de france
devrait commencer début avril